Rakuten Travel operates Japan's largest internet hotel reservation site,...
...serving an accumulative total of over 100 million users as of 2008.
The reason we upgraded to Oracle Database 11G...
...was to serve more customers by expanding the system capability.
Another reason for upgrading to Oracle Database 11G was to boost data search speeds.
Currently, we are using Oracle Automatic Storage Management...
...and Oracle Clusterware as a foundation for all our Rakuten Travel systems.
In addition, we are using Oracle Enterprise Manager for managing operations.
We chose Oracle Database products,...
...primarily because they enable us to offer a more stable service to our customers on a continuous basis.
Also, we highly value Oracle's extremely comprehensive support system.
By investing in Oracle database and hardware upgrades,...
...we have been able to achieve a 60% increase in performance,...
...providing the maximum return for the least investment.
By using Automatic Storage Management,...
...we have been able to reduce operational and management cost,...
...by eliminating the work our database engineers had to perform two to three times a month.
In the past when we needed to add nodes, we had to shut down the database system.
But now with the adoption of Oracle Clusterware, we are able to add nodes online,...
...reducing the amount of downtime to the bare minimum.
Amid the current austere economic conditions,...
...Oracle has helped us a great deal: generating the maximum return...
...whilst cutting downtime and keeping cost to the minimum.